and march 18th i'm in seattle 19th
portland march 25th las vegas nevada and
just real quickly i have my second
comedy special coming out at youtube.com
christy comedy sometime in late march so
subscribe now i'm very very proud of it
directed by the homeless pimp then we're
going april 15th and 16th louisville and
evansville april 23rd and 24th
tulsa and oklahoma city and then we got
may 14th at the beacon and may 21st and
22nd san diego and la salvano comedy.com
don't run away from your feelings babe
don't be afraid don't be ashamed don't
hesitate take me home tonight i don't
wanna let you go till you see the lights
take me home tonight listen honey just
like rice said
be my little hey babe
hey babe hey what's going on babies
these are pimp's christmas gifts that he
gave us in march
it's a sleepy joke it's a sleepy joe
hoodie sleepy joe hoodie and then we
have joe in between us right
this is like here yeah
pee-wee herman it does that would that
this is a christmas gift that pimp uh
gave to um us on the last episode and we
just we would have it out on this
episode i'm gonna bring this home to my
children and see what happens what is it
exactly well in goosebumps it was like a
haunted uh friendship r.l stein r.l
stein oh we know that person do you know
arnold stein personally uh murray does
really yeah yeah big guy short guy no
idea didn't even know it was a guy
uh murray's murray's friends with him i
suppose uh or because every time murray
puts out a book
r.l stein is one of the people on like
the jacket like
horrific you know not a kind of guy it
looks like murray oh wow he does look
like harlow like
he looks like uh
what does he look like arnold stein he
kind of looks like um
arnold stein looks a little bit like uh
he looks like somebody i can't get it
who looks like a old uh old not famous
just kind of regular jeff goldblum
yeah
he looks all stein's net worth hit me
with that ready for this
350 million dollars yeah i think it's i
think it's got to be about 150 million
200 million you got closer wow you got
close you can punch me in the face
that's a lot of cash bro that's a lot of
cash flow
that's uh but he ain't got that podcast
money nah kid net worth that means he
could liquidate for 200 mil that's
insane man cause what does net worth
really mean
like that's like you know like like
like the cost of my house that goes into
my net worth oh of course the entire
cost of the house it's equity or the
economy
so far yeah of course
yeah right so you know if you bought a
house for a million bucks and you put
you paid 300 off if you have a 700
mortgage you have 300 equity in the
house that goes toward your net worth
right yeah that's what you go liquid for
go liquid for three
and then
i mean well it's not what you look for
it's your equity still counts as your
net worth right but it's just like
sometimes people will have like tons of
money in network but it's all tied up
and it's not really like extremely rich
people well not even extremely rich
people people are smart with their money
um they never really use their own money
like they buy all these properties and
they just always they're all about bank
loans they're all about using everybody
else's money yeah and never their own
money that's like a thing that i'm
trying to learn now it's like get invest
in something but don't use as little of
your own money as possible use the
bank's money but then aren't you paying
the interest on it so you are but you're
basically paying
yeah but you could always like if you
turn it over and sell it and you cover
your costs you know you could be there
for really not losing anything because
you're you are getting equity in it
you're paying interest rates inflation
all that stuff but then if you sell it
enough to cover your costs and the
closing costs and the taxes and all that
stuff you can make a profit and or break
even and then it's not like you really
spent your money on it but that's if you
want to like if you have enough money to
to buy multiple properties or you you're
content with consistently moving around
and stuff otherwise you're tying your
money up what does sweat equity mean
then
i think that's like basically a measure
of
how much
putting a a tangible dollar amount on
the work
that you put into something that not
necessarily its value so sweat sweat
equity like you built a brand right it
took a long time right so if someone's
gonna buy your brand and not just you
might say like well there's all the
sweat equity as well sweat quitting
i would say equity yes i wouldn't say
sweat equity i would say my sweat
quitting
uh sweat quitting say three times fast
smuggling spock when he's [ __ ] he
nailed it so equity or sweat equity as
some idiots call it is the ownership
interest or increase in value that is
created as a direct result of hard work
by the owner it is the preferred mode of
building equity for cash-strapped
entrepreneurs in their start-up ventures
since they may be unable to contribute
much financial capital to their
enterprise right so you know when people
go on shark tank you're like i have this
amazing idea i've been fostering it for
a while this was the first prototype
this is the second now we have it where
it needs to be we have found all this
stuff we named it this is the market and
it's like but we just have no we need to
scale we have no money we have not and
they say what's your valuation sometimes
they'll put a valuation on it and the
valuation can't be exactly what the
thing is worth because it's not worth
anything yet right but it has evaluation
because they had to put all that sweat
equity and hard work into getting it
where it was to present time so there's
a value in that right so can you have
sweat equity in like a house
i don't know if it works that way it's
really like a business is what you get
yes sweat equity i mean sweat equity is
just building that happening pulled up a
sweatwitty example um the name is
episode so equity an example of sweat
equity is a person who spends time
renovating homes and selling them at a
higher price the difference between the
value of the home before renovations and
the market value the whole after repairs
represents sweat equity okay that's
understandable yeah but we bought a
house for a million we put in 200k in it
but then we sold it for
one million three hundred we make a
hundred grand
sweat equity well if you paid to have it
put in
i don't know if that's you have
improvements on the house but if you did
it yourself you're giving yourself value
by your own work i think that's the
difference got it so if you renovated
your whole house by yourself
right you didn't get paid you didn't get
paid for that but it's worth that when
it nets out got it you understood i
think i mean that's how i pick it up
because when they flip a house when you
flip a house it's pretty much you just
buying a house and then renovating it
for a cheap price and then selling it
like you really like when you flip
houses you don't make like a ton of
money no well i guess it all depends it
all depends yeah okay flip them flip
flops interesting this is uh welcome
we're in the new property brothers what
is the seventy percent i asked to get
the property sisters i asked to get on
that show and what they said i reached
out i love it i'll come on anytime and
they were like all right it was like on
twitter but then i never went on
my girl uh i s this is a true story one
time watching property brothers years
ago now you lying
prove it
[Laughter]
and she goes um and and and she's like
like like you know like a little bit
later she's like oh why don't we watch
like i want to watch the show with the
lovers on i love the lovers and i said
what do you mean she's like the show
with the love the two lovers that
renovate stuff and i'm like watching
like the guys the gay guys the gay
lovers and i go are you talking to her
you talking about property brothers she
goes yeah i go you think this guy's a
gay lover she goes yeah what do you mean
i go there i
tend to go to
there's no other way you can't be more
identical than identical and she's like
no no no and i pulled up the picture and
she goes they look alike but i don't
think they're identical twins i'm like
it's
called property brothers
oh my gosh she thought she told she's
like i call property lovers she goes she
goes here she goes what's my favorite
show the property homos
wow what is you know my father's a twin
no my father has a tampa somebody else
well there's a there was a tampa and
helen she passed away uh 20 years ago
now but she was a female oh
he said like even though it's male
female you know not identical
connect really said you happy new year
think about that i mean the closest
person to you probably on earth is is
your sibling already right let alone
twin
twin i mean it's insane to have we're
not you know i have two two kids now i
was i was thinking like wow mine's one
of these is a twin like you know it's
very difficult to raise like a little
baby but fans out there that have twins
that have twins is like i can't i i
wouldn't even know how to manage that
really especially like you know i know
there's some people out there that can
afford a nanny or twins in my family
really yeah when your siblings uh
cousins like and it was their mom
was it hard to write i mean mom was a
bit exhausted i guess it's challenging
i heard i heard two at once it's crazy
because they make they wake each other
up yeah two-on-ones is crazy and then
and i also heard like you know when you
have like that second kid is like crazy
to be honest i have three kids in the
house now i've you know my 11 year old
steps on my six-year-old daughter and uh
not an eight-month-old daughter and
just even though you know the focus you
know the six-year-old eleven-year-old
can you know they brush their teeth they
you know do their homework whatever
having three children is it is like
where you're like oh my god like there's
so many things to do always it's awesome
but it's like i would say for sure i'm
way more tired
with this third kid then like two kids
they say one kid is nothing when you
have two kids it's really insane and
three kids it's like crazy off the wall
i would say it is off the wall michael
jackson have you ever met quintuplets
like somebody would print up one five
five babies born in one birth i mean
what are we kittens that's crazy man
what about the octo mom how'd she do it
i know should i see that picture of her
belly the octomom it looks like she
swallowed a legitimate boulder from
colorado yeah like huge yeah yeah that
like look at a rip she is how is her
body not tearing in half
also how are there eight kids just
flopping around in there now was that in
vitro like was that or did she like was
this just like
this just happened
oh you know what where are these kids
now what do these kids look like yeah
whatever oh look there it is show that
set
like what's going on in there man what
is going on in there and every single
one
everything so many babies that's not
even that's what three
did every single one of them survive
yeah she had eight kids by the eighth
kid popping out does he is it just fully
numb did she go naturally she was ivf
conducted by okay seem to have requested
transfer of six errors that she had
accumulated from previous despite being
informed at the recommended guideline
for limit her age so she did this on
purpose this wasn't like
whoa the octuplets and her
six older children
were all conceived using one other man's
sperm she said through a spokesperson
absolutely dennis is definitely not the
father how many kids does octomom have
total
is octomom married oh not anymore she
did 14 kids through ivf wow she has 14
kids
which like you know now is insane but
back in the day that was like this was
very normal how do you yeah well my
grandparents like but how do you afford
that even 14 kids how do you afford 14
kids
how do you even you need a system you
need a you need you need a literal
system in the house
imagine raising eight at once they
birthed at once yeah so there's there's
no way to there's no way yeah you're not
doing that you need help you you need
the government has to send somebody they
got to send somebody yeah you can't feed
eight kids at the same time they all on
schedules right but about them all
staying up waking up you know better
than anyone you dealt with it how do you
have eight kids at one time
they ain't enough you there ain't there
ain't a big enough titty in the world to
feed all eight kids i know the titties
that's gonna be and and and listen i
know there's someone out there with some
big old titties
but but even even in big old remaining
ways yeah there's still not enough big o
to feed a child think of that saying
think of the biggest city you've ever
seen oh
not enough for h
the biggest thing i've seen you know who
you are liz what up girl
man liz strollman you know how it is
[Laughter]
um
oh in 20 000 2012 here's how she paid
for it suleiman octo mom starred in the
film 666 the devil's child a low budget
horror film that centers upon a couple
that visits a woman they met on the
internet only for strange things to
occur like the one of the women has
eight kids at once like she was accused
of welfare fraud by the california state
of california well failing to disclose
nearly 30 000 in earnings i'll get off
come on 30 grand come on you [ __ ] she
pleaded no contest
to a single count of misdemeanor welfare
fraud disclosed income she was receiving
from videos and personal appearances
while collecting more than 26 000
assistants i mean come on man that's
right
that's not her october porn
no stop it
she looks like tt jerry there octomom
home alone
wait what what
celebrity and recognition pornographic
film peach featuring prominent american
mother nadia suleiman that's her
so she did a full porn
mom no
she was under severe sign financial
pressure from raising 14 children
publicly say that she would not do porn
she explained that
say saying i'm a been celibate 14 years
and i'm a regular church-goer she also
claimed she never masturbated she's a
nun
god i've never masturbated anyone who
says they never masturbated i i i
honestly if a guy tells me he's never
masturbated i'm going to go to the store
and get a poncho because i know that you
masturbate more than anyone
i've ever met in my life i had a coach
once tell me he's never masturbated i
was like what the shut up you've never
masturbated couldn't that be painful
weird that my coach said that like
it was even it was even more orders
while you were blowing them yeah i know
he was like ah what is this stuff coming
out of my pee pee
mom home alone was nominated for four
atm awards best celebrity sex i i had
never heard actually can we pull up octo
like is there a still image from this
like this is like one of those things i
don't want to watch the tape but i'm
just saying like is there you know
i mean i would be interested in seeing
what the tapes what's going on with this
tape yeah who directed it
i don't want to see it now octo mom home
alone if you go to yougiz.com
you could yeah i'm not interested i'm
just not interested yeah it doesn't feel
right what are you going you just you
porn pornhub 8th street latinas what do
you do
before i i will answer that because i
just don't i don't you know i'm not i'm
not a loyal to any one of them right but
look at the guy she's with can you
scroll up he looks like a look at he
look how thin
he's he's like so thin and so tan he's
like a chocolate wafer yeah
it's almost he's almost in blackface
like it's her 23 year old bodybuilder
boyfriend i know he is almost he's so
like chocolatey yeah shout out to
chocolate i love chocolate what
literally what is a better sweet than
chocolate truthfully i don't i mean i
think that you'd be hard-pressed to find
i think everybody would agree i think
it's a drug isn't it is it a drug i
think it has like properties of like
addiction
homeless pimp when's the last time you
eat a piece of chocolate with your
healthy diet um you're special taping
well you had chocolate yeah there was
chocolate oh but it was dark chocolate
what about a real like piece of [ __ ]
like it was like the bark thin thing
yeah like what about like a i'm talking
about like a when's the last time you
ate like a like a true idiot
like in a year like you think you've
been had a year of like probably uh
july
july yeah that's isn't that wild that
you can get to that level i know i'm
trying to reverse now i'm trying to be
but you just ordered would you wear a
thin mint shake yeah but we got grilled
chicken
[Laughter]
one time a nutritionist told me instead
of concentrating on what you on on all
the bad food you ate just try to eat the
right foods right as long as you get the
right foods and which is such a dumb
thing to tell me yeah yeah but his whole
philosophy is is because the more and
more you eat the right foods and you
feel how your body feels at that it's a
process right and you'll get you'll get
there quick all right
the problem is with me the problem is
with me is when i get out of shape which
i am right now nobody notices it but me
so it's tough when somebody's like no
you look great you don't feel out of
shape to me i've oh dude i mean really
girl
but girl i feel like i got octo mom tips
oh you've been boxing and stuff yeah but
baby girl it ain't enough yeah but
sweetie don't do that to yourself you're
looking in the mirror and only you're
seeing that boo you know i appreciate
you and everything you do for me and my
family yeah but i do feel uh disgusting
and i have stretch marks on my thighs
nobody's seeing those stretch marks
really no come on now i'll pull them out
[Laughter]
speaking of stretch marks yeah and i've
been moisturizing as our pal john
rennisky cease yeah uh johnny art yeah
john robinski roddick shout
100 i've moisturized my face every
single day i've washed my hair with
shampoo one time since then the morning
of my special no [ __ ] and i'm telling
you dude you're feeling my hair even
even my mother commented on she's like
when did your hair get so wavy i'm like
i've just been using conditioner and
water so this whole time i'm washing my
hair i've been
naturally he said he said all the
natural oils and your hair you know it
looks stringy because you wash it too
much yeah that's because i knew that
that ate my hair and now and i have to
wash mine every day now though which
shampoo well
if if i don't it gets it's so long it
looks too greasy
you know what i mean right
what are you doing about the uh mullet
cut it off
you did yes you're done with it now i
cut it off yeah all right so you had a
haircut since the mullet yeah yeah see
when it gets long i go like every two
months i kind of realized like this
isn't me when i looked at i said you
know what it was a fun idea but what i
am committed to though is growing my
hair out
in what way my hair is right now my hair
is like pandemic length like in the you
know when we couldn't get haircuts yeah
it's like it's it's approaching that now
i want to grow out to like like i want
to i want to have fl i want to have long
hair and see what happens are you how
serious are you being with me right now
are you going to go for your next
haircut and get his fade or are you
going to grow your hair no i go to my
haircut my my barber uh uh shout out
jeremy i go to my barber and
someone in the public that has the
hairstyle you want so i can we can
understand what you're visualizing john
rodnicki
right cooper okay um
john ranitzky bradley cooper billie jean
king right
yeah so jeremy jeremy you tell you
jeremy's going to bring you there jeremy
shout out i'm from soho cartel
barbershop oh
he got my hair live on the chris cass
podcast and um
and uh he's he knows what i want and he
said you know i had to cut the mullet so
he said he had to like shape it up a
little bit he said but now when he comes
over it'll just be shape ups wow wow
coming to the house a little extra
bubble yeah i'd love to see it though
yeah i'm going to grow it out man i want
to know what you're looking at why not
because i said you know what man
who knows how long we have our hair for
yeah you know i mean obviously if we use
keeps.com we can always get him out of
it promo code hey babe
all that they do yeah um but keep what
you have keep what you have it doesn't
yeah two or three minutes doesn't grow
your hair back does not yeah um but i i
think that i want to just grow the hair
out you know like my father told me the
other day it was interesting my father
was with me shout out to amputee and i
was on the floor like uh you know
messing with the baby's father's tt2 tt
wow
tt jerry dt daddy tt jerry tt daddy yeah
good very smart yeah and
and i was i was on my hands and knees
like crawling after the baby like just
being silly and my dad said to me like
earnestly he was like you don't know i
would give everything
to just be able to go on my hands and
knees again just one more time again in
my life and be able to get up and not be
in excruciating pain or be able to do
that he's like enjoy your knees while
you have them and i was like wow we
don't think it was like profound because
yeah just he's that's what he's saying
he's like one day i just woke up and
that was the last day my knees worked
like you know what i mean like that's
terrifying it just but he said it's just
what it is wow you know
and you know it is another sin another
um problem you know as older men like
our brains women's brains this is like a
a study a real science thing women's
like i forgot what chemicals it is but i
i guess when they go through menopause
like their
desire to have sex like goes down and
they don't
they have a track you know like sex it's
not an excitable thing for them as much
anymore it just goes down the urge goes
down men it doesn't so your brain wants
to have as much sex as it did when it
was 20 as it does when it's 90. it's
just your body really
oh your brain does brain does you can't
do it right but it's brain that's why
there's a very high rate of stds in
nursing homes
is that true very high google std right
now
davey [ __ ] in there baby [ __ ] who
be again
grandma and grandpa no yes ma'am no
historical down low look historic high
rates of stis among older americans
february 26 2020 that's what caused the
pandemic wait what's the difference
between std and sti
sexual transmitting infection versus
sexually transmitted disease what's the
difference
i never heard of an sti
i think it's just the new updated term
for it oh no way yeah like you you can't
call them like you know you don't call
them you know um
whatever
manhole covers anymore now they're
people hole covers or they're fire
people do you really believe sti is is
std
sti std and sexually transmitted these
are sti i mean sexually transmitted
infection
the difference is between a disease and
infection
not all diseases begin with infections
but many do
sexually transmitted disease first
begins as a sexually transmitted
infection
whatever bro
so they're in there and they're like
sneaking around and having sex in that
one of the most comforting things in the
world is just to be in a relationship
and know you don't have an std and if
you do have an std at least you got it
from a cheating partner and like you
don't have to like search around you
know what i mean you live your life good
yeah i mean i i didn't realize how long
when i was single like how much of my
time was worried about having an std
almost 90 percent of my day
any pain i felt in my genitalia at all i
was like i got an std i got it i got an
std and now it's like whatever dude i'm
just dying of prostate cancer
releasing an std i was told i had to get
a i was told that the colonoscopy age is
45 now i got a colonoscopy after 35. why
because i
thought that my poo looked very strange
and i took a photo of it in the toilet
bowl and it was a very glossy photo i
must have had some type of filter on but
i showed that to the doctor and he was
like i've never seen poop that looks
like plastic like that i was like i
swear that's my poop he was like there's
no filter i said no but
i was just so nervous that i didn't
realize that there was and then he was
like well we should do a colonoscopy
just knock anything out and then they
looked in and they said i had like a
little polyp but he said it was like
[ __ ] what's the process back at 45
what's the process there
you drink a a a
juice a colon blow whatever the hell is
it yeah and then you have to literally
they tell you they're like bring a
laptop bring a book bring the kids bring
the family into the bathroom sure
because you cannot get up because you
are constantly flowing with diarrhea and
it gets to the point where at the end of
it like the the morning of you're just
fully [ __ ] lick like like there's
nothing in your intestine in your gut
like you full gut
well this is before you get to that
before and then i went to i took an uber
uh because you have to go with somebody
but they said do not drive because
you're like you can't drive back
so i took an uber
um you can't drive because you're gonna
[ __ ] yourself no because uh you go under
anesthesia oh sure so i took an uber
there you get out completely completely
out completely out completely out i
don't know if i like this
completely not you ever been under
anesthesia
probably for uh dentistry no this is
real anesthesia i dude being under
anesthesia is in
i'm assuming no dude they literally are
like all right count backwards from 100.
and then i got to 97 and i woke up and
it was done
like done it's actually insane
what are you what are you wearing and
like who's going up who's who's locating
your holes
and then who's penetrating them uh in
what fashion who else is around so there
were two doctors there was an asian man
um who's the anesthesiologist who said
you know you're gonna have the greatest
sleep of your life and then there was an
uh indian man uh my doctor who was like
i'm gonna take this rod and shove it up
your ass right and you're not gonna feel
anything right and and uh is it a rod
it's a long like cable that has like it
looks like a hose and it's got a little
camera at the end of it the worst thing
that was nothing actually you don't even
feel anything
before you were out right but to get to
that level for them to test you they
want they needed to test my prostate for
some reason that sucked because that's a
woman like it was a russian nurse who
was you know pretty attractive that i
had to just get in the gown and you know
she opened up my [ __ ] and put like it
looked like a microphone in my ass and i
was like ah
like screaming and she was like just a
little more just a little more
and she kept saying that and i was like
this is killing me she's like little
more a little more
wait so you went to this place you put
on a gown you and his russian woman are
in a room alone yes you bend over no i
had to lay on the table in the fetal
position and they moved one leg
on my side i had to move my legs like
this to open up my [ __ ] as much as i
could and then they she came and i felt
her grab a cheek
and listen yes and then she went in like
that and i was like ah and she i
remember she just kept going little more
a little more she kept saying little
more
yeah so will you did you speak to her
beforehand have you ever seen her before
how long before you your eyes saw her
was she shoving something up your ass
30 seconds 30 seconds put on the glove
she said you'll name chris
that was yep you said no pleasantries
and then she said okay lay on your side
cause i already had my gown on with my
ass out and then she uh lay on the side
i feel weird here what else she said to
me too she goes this is not her school
professional she goes you have mole on
back you should take a look
i was like okay thank you um
and uh and uh you you walked in you saw
over the first time she goes get up on
table yeah and then you got up she and
then
she lifts your cheek oh is that hold on
is that the food
oh it's santino
has your mind been sprinting for years
on end leaving trails of stress anxiety
and fatigue that are eroding your mental
health ding ding ding ding yes if you're
nodding along yes it's time to adopt
small daily practices that'll have a
huge impact on your long-term happiness
and well-being it's easy to learn that
with headspace
headspace.com hey babe you're going to
get the best offer available to feel
right to feel good it's easy to learn
with head space if you're not alone yes
which we know you are then it's time to
adopt small daily practices that will
have a huge impact on your long-term
happiness and well-being which is what i
also said and you're driving at home
in fact you ready for this in fact to
answer your question sal that may or may
not have been edited out a recent study
proved in just two weeks headspace can
reduce your stress by 14
what that's 14 that is that's
significant 14 what whether you want to
relieve stress and anxiety sleep better
or improve your focus head space is your
everyday dose of mindfulness for real
life i love meditating man and the only
way i can meditate is with head space
truthfully oh love a good meditation yes
especially if i have it in an app form
yeah it's on my my smartphone it goes
where i go i can meditate uh when i'm
trying to fall asleep i can meditate
when i'm on the subway i can meditate
when i'm on the airplane i can meditate
in a car i can meditate uh meditate in
the bar i could maybe on a truck i could
meditate in a rut
headspace.com
slash hey babe
all right so cute it's hello fresh time
oh
america's number one
with hellofresh you get farm fresh pre
portion ingredients and seasonal recipes
deliver right to your dough step skip
trips to the grocery store and count on
hello fresh to me i wish i had an accent
like that why can't it's so much more
fun how hello fresh what i love about
them is it's low calorie carb conscious
options they got six recipes per week to
choose from babe they just came out with
like this cheese
beef tenderloin cheese fondue fondue it
was so good i literally i took a bite of
it and i slapped my six-year-old in the
face with it because that was so good
oh you're so cute you just wanted her to
know i wanted to know it was up with
hellofresh yeah and that's that's what
it is also the miso sesame shrimp and
bacon ramen i thought it was so
delicious i took my neighbor's dog and i
just shoved it right down yeah and
right down his throat and then because i
was like this dog's so cute and he needs
to try this and i i dipped that dog in
the fondue it was fantastic yeah
hellofresh is 72 cheaper than a
restaurant meal of the same quality and
you can save on average
65 per month when you order hellofresh
instead of grocery shopping 20 minute
recipes 30 minute recipes uh low prep
easy clean up order online or in the app
you can change your delivery day your
food preferences your plan sizes you're
gonna skip weeks and you want the
flexibility is bonkers bonkers if you
can't clean it up and cook it right
you're an idiot you you literally idiot
go to the doctor diagnosed with idiot
yeah you're not using america's number
one meal kid you know what he's gonna do
he'll write your prescription for
hellofresh hellofresh hellofresh and the
the code if you use the code haters
use the code hey babe 16 and use code go
to hellofresh.com hey babe 16. use the
code hey babe16 you're going to get 16
free meals and three free gifts the
three free gifts is ambiguous and i love
that about it yeah well it's almost like
a mini christmas one of the gifts was
this sweatshirt yes that's that's sleepy
joe derosa
hellofresh.com16 used to code hey babe
16 16 free meals and three free gifts
because i think we're supposed to be on
a call at four o'clock oh but it's not
it's not four o'clock yet um
you kill her you feel her palm your ass
and palm island she literally no
literally though i'm asking you
she grabbed your ass and lifted it up
look i was rolled over like this look
like she she told me to go like this
okay and i'm rolled over like what about
you both
they're there okay so and then
and then so i'm laying like this yeah
yeah you know imagine this is here so i
got my whole leg over so i'm ex this is
it's open already it is open and then
she goes she takes her she had the thing
in her right hand i believe it was her
right hand she takes the thing in her
right hand she takes her left hand and
pulls open my ass and then gets right in
there and then i felt my cheek collapse
onto it and then i was like
and then and then you really were going
and then i was like it's cold and she
goes yes and then i was like i was like
i was like oh and then she kept going
and i was like stop little more little
more a little more and then i was like
this is killing me and then she goes a
little more and then i remember she
pulled it out and you heard like
oh like it came out like that yeah was
it was what was bothering you how deep
and she was going or how wide it was
both deep and wide oh and i remember she
pulled it out and she was like you're
done and i laid there for about 20
seconds what was this
uh to get broad prostate looked at what
was she shoving in there
i don't know like some inch a prostate
checking instrument all right
yeah
and
like like i literally and then what and
then and then she then you sat back up
yeah and got dressed got dressed and
left like that didn't just happen
like i didn't know but i didn't know
what i was expecting like i thought like
i was going to be like that you know
like like a guy like a gynecologist
yeah
so i
and that's before that
description by the way yeah with the
colonoscope
yeah uh you you you what was that like
you don't feel anything so you go out
and then you wake up and you're done and
you don't know what they did what it
felt like what happened colonoscopy by
the way general anesthesia works by
interrupting nerve signals in your brain
and body it prevents your brain from
processing pain and from remembering
what happened during your surgery so
it knocks you out yeah
why does it prevent you from remembering
what happened
i don't know general anesthesia relaxes
the muscles in your digestive tract and
airway that keep food and acid from
passing your stomach into your lungs
always follow your doctor's instructions
about avoiding food and drink for
surgery yeah you can't eat i remember
that i remember with the colonoscopy you
i couldn't eat for 24 hours i want to
say 24 hours i couldn't eat and then i
take the colon blow so you know you know
you're you're [ __ ] everything out
that was in your stomach and like cleans
your tracks because they need to
basically they can't have any bowel
right you can't go in there and see a
good bird is that a tumor or a chicken
bone right yeah right so they need
everything out but then you're starving
and then i got the procedure my
procedure was that in the afternoon at
like 1 p.m
so i had to like wait all day and you're
like almost like passing out yeah and
then they do it and then i remember like
then you could eat whatever you want i
like ran
to get food i got um uh bear burger bear
burger which is the hell out of here
from uh the place that i went i went
down on williams street were you were
you leading up to the appointment were
you like full of anxiety like nervous
and like weird you know what i was i had
so much anxiety because i never had a
procedure for anything in my life i was
like one of those never anything in the
hospital nothing
so i had a lot of nerves but i got to be
honest with you after i got the
anesthesia and i whatever got through it
not that this is that big of a deal it's
a very routine thing but i felt like
this like
like not nervous about a hospital or any
like i just wasn't nervous about it
anymore
i kind of got like a little like all
right acclimated the worst comes to
worse and i ever need a surgery just get
the anesthesia it's over right you know
like it's whatever don't don't be so
worried and and they they're so
professional they treat you with such
good care that it was like who who are
these guys how did you find them the the
the um i
general general practitioner no i i i
wish i wish there was some type of
sponsor but the truth is i just went on
zocdoc and uh
sock doc and i just put in my insurance
um
and and and i i um it was none how much
was it calling off we got a park
i don't even remember five g's maybe you
you paid five thousand dollars out of
pocket to have two men you didn't know
go up your ass with a tube for this yeah
yep
uh i didn't have insurance at the time
oh my god but i had to get it done wow
yeah what what are the results what do
you know if i have insurance now because
i haven't been done anything with the
screen actors guild and i don't i might
not have health insurance right now what
was i saying to the doctor
why do you get to have insurance
through jasmine really yeah oh dude
that's a little dangerous
did i have insurance i know right i must
have it though right
i couldn't tell you i mean you had do
you have insurance through the screen
actors yeah because joker's is sag
no it's not but i've done i do seg
projects all the time so i i had it
through something else and i transferred
to seg when i was eligible i mean which
is like blue you name this episode i do
sag projects all the time
[Laughter]
i mean joker's is not but i had you have
to do them enough
to keep it is what i mean i don't think
i've done anything i do them enough
is what i should say to keep it going
right oh god you do sad stuff
i don't know i don't think i don't think
anything i've been on in the last year
has been okay but damn what are they
looking for when they do the colonoscopy
they're looking for polyps they're
looking for cancer they're looking
through your colon and what'd they find
they found a polyp but it was like they
said it was [ __ ] yeah it's a
[ __ ] one like not like
zero to worry about like they said
actually i don't have to come in again
until i'm 50 now not 45. they told me
50. i'm going to go 45 but they said 50.
so bro i'm 45. never gotten no do you
have any problems never 45. i've never
been called and asked it happens baby do
you do i have problems like in what way
do you feel
like that you have any type of colon
issues not that i
could imagine you never [ __ ] blood ever
once in your life in my life yeah i have
to imagine by the way
quick tip but always look at the toilet
bowl before you flush because there's a
lot of times where you might have stuff
in the toilet bowl that you like don't
want to look at and i get it but
it it says a lot about the health of
your body if you're you know if you have
floating poop it your poop should always
be s shaped light brown in color and
have no blood
okay and floating
she was floating i'm sorry it should
sink sink to the bottom should not be
floating if you're floating that means
you have too much fat and fat in your
diet really it's a digestive issue yep
wow oh yeah
all right yep that's probably the food
okay well here well who's hungry
where are we at [ __ ]
yeah we're good 34.
um
all right sorry close up call
colonoscopy by city or living in one of
the most expensive cities to get a
colonoscopy my friend eleven to thirty
seven hundred bucks so do you think that
i should
do you think that i should call and get
a colonoscopy well if if they said it's
45 get it yeah i mean that's what i am
why not i don't know man i just you
nervous about it i don't know no one's
i've never been put under than people go
into my body through my eggs did you
ever have anyone in your family that had
colon cancer or any type of no i'm sure
my dad said cancer and my mom does
cancer running your family in any way
shape or form no no not really not not
in my immediate and immediate are you
sure it's 45 and not 50.
wow as long as you order the right foods
you're fine yeah oh we got a thin
chicken mint i know but we got to split
that looks dynamite i know
it looks like good food
um
this episode might get cut a little
short mikey kylo short only because
we've got a thin mint shake that we're
looking at and some food from shout out
jay's on the bay shout out jason babe
you filmed this special
honey bunny right now it's march 17th
you filmed it just a couple of weeks ago
st patrick's day it's today that's why i
got the thin mention oh my god another
thing shout out by the way speaking of
st patrick shout out tom brady yes and
patrick
but what they did a couple of super
bowls ago he won in tampa at 43 years
old but not to be outdone that that team
with patty mahomes is unbelievable
fast forward though matthew stafford and
the los angeles rams won another one
their super bowl game at home yeah
defeating the i don't even remember
who looks like homeless pimp that's
correct so just
bro scrappy ball club those bengals yeah
and uh you know there you go
this looks pretty cool
look at
so my comedy special uh which is coming
out at youtube.com says christie comedy
my youtube channel uh the last week of
march yeah which we believe we're going
to call i am poppy i filmed it at the
gramercy theater i'm very proud of it
directed by the homeless pimp himself um
we're really proud of it and uh and dude
it was amazing it's good to get that
material out there and kind of you know
move on from it and write new jokes and
do new things but
and it was fun man it was fun i mean the
second show people were hammer drunk um
at one point i i took a man's truly and
started drinking it on stage and pimp
was like you can't have a truly it's a
taping of course so i was like yep i'm a
dummy and um and uh you watched two
shrek movies in the green room i watched
shrek 1 and shrek 2 to prepare for it i
watched shrek 1 before the first show
shrek 2 before the second show i still
got to see those
the fact that you still haven't seen
shrek is it it's a little bit you know
what maybe i'll watch it tonight want to
do that maybe i'll watch it tonight
should we do a live watch on the
that's nice patreon soon which yeah no
but the merch really is out it's out
actually now the merch is out the merch
is out it's at salvocanocomedy.com and
christycody.com just go to store store
it's on there um but yeah no dude i'm
excited about i think the putting a
comedy special out on youtube now
feels like the way to go because i've
said this before is you know my career
really only started to get started in a
real way when
i put my power put the power of my
career in the hands of my fans not a in
corporation right so um so that's why i
put on youtube and i you know i just
hope you guys like it share it please it
uh it'd be good
and if you're coming tomorrow to my
shows in seattle and portland it will be
uh different material than that so yeah
i was supposed to issue that so what do
you got lined up now so i got i got i
got about 20-ish minutes that are not on
the special okay um and then you know do
some crowd work have some fun you know
but but you're looking for 40 there
looking for 40 well i don't know i might
put out we might put out 30 30 to 40 now
because now all these algorithms the
bottom line is like the hour special is
just it's like dude
church catholic mass at least used to be
two and a half hours and then it went
down to 45 minutes because it's like the
thing like
even dave chappelle like who i love is
like i can't watch it for 60 minutes
right 30 minutes i can watch it but 60
is like come on it's too long right
there's too many distractions so that's
what we're thinking is what we'll put
out is most likely 30. um
because a live performance is different
when you're live it's like you're in the
zone you're in the venue you know it's
interactive but sitting at home and just
making you watch something that you have
to pay attention to for 60 minutes yeah
i think is a big ask okay in 2022 of a
person personally um but you know listen
it's what it is we're gonna put it out
and uh and yeah and then and i feel good
like i've been i was having a really
tough time writing new material uh for
these past year or two yeah um because i
think i just and i was getting very
angry with my material because i think i
just wanted to put it out and i was mad
i'm like why is there not why is this
not a special right and now that it's
out all of a sudden i have like six new
ideas in my head because you need to
because i just needed to like expel it
yeah you know because now it's like i
can't do that material i'm sick of my
routine you know what i mean i'm
figuring out if i'm gonna tape in july
or january you're gonna do especially
when she for for for youtube but what
are you gonna do well we'll see we'll
see i got a couple of targets and if i
don't hit those i might just go to
youtube because that's the way what
title do you like better do you like i
am poppy better or especially wishy
listen i used to tell you that this
podcast was sponsored by betterhelp now
i tell you this podcast is sponsored by
betterhelp online therapy that's true
look
go ahead babe talk to you we were
talking about investing before but i
want to ask you myself did you ever
invest in yourself i do i'm investing in
myself yeah i don't sometimes but then i
do to make up all the times i didn't and
right now i am investing in myself and
let me tell you something right now i am
at my wit's end
yeah i am lately at my wits end and i
need better i i use better help with
those glasses in that hair you look like
a nut job like relief pitcher
i look like the guy from uh like ricky
vaughn yeah like a maniac
fire in 99 yeah high and tight look
relationships take work
a lot of us will drop by anything to go
help someone else but we don't help
ourselves you know you don't help
yourself i do therapy i'm starting to
exercise again i start counting calories
yeah i want to get my mental state to
reflect and then then the inside the
good inside comes out now better help
it's online therapy that offers video
phone and even live chat sessions with
your therapist you don't have to see
anyone on camera if you don't want to
i've used it it literally it helps so
much just to talk to somebody because
there's times where it's like you know i
just got to talk to somebody and better
help has they have great it's great
professional therapy yeah it's it's it's
affordable it's more affordable than
in-person therapy uh match with a
therapist in under 48 hours two million
people have used the better uh help
online therapy uh there are too many
people in that community that's
unbelievable right uh yeah so you know
we we we love it we we we say the
podcast is sponsored by betterhelp and
hey babe listeners get 10 off their
first month at betterhelp.com hey babe
try it out you got nothing to lose
that's b e t t e r h e l p dot com slash
hey babe college basketball fans join
the action on the court during the
biggest tournament of the year with
draftkings sportsbook it's march
madness turn your team's victory into
your own big win new customers can bet
five dollars five dollars here on any
team to win and get two hundred dollars
in free bets if they do it's that simple
if you win
if they win you win if sportsbook isn't
available in your state you can still
join the college hoops action with the
draftkings pools or move out of that
state everyone can play free pools all
march long for a shot at a share of over
250
thousand dollars in prizes simply join a
pool and answer questions like hey who
will make to the next round and who will
hit the most three pointers then track
your results
that's fun that is fun download your
download the draftking sportsbook app
now and use promo code hey babe bet five
dollars on any college hoops team to win
and get 200 in free bets if they do
again if they win you win cutes with
promo code hey babe this week at
draftkings sportsbook 21 years of age or
older restrictions apply see show notes
for details here we go i'll read it now
if you or someone you know has a
gambling problem christ counseling
referral services can be accessed by
calling 1-800 gambler that's
1-800-426-2537
illinois indiana
minnesota new jersey pennsylvania west
virginia wyoming 1-800 next step visit
for arizona oh for arizona 100 next up
for arizona 1-8005 1-800-522-4700
uh 888-789-777
uh visit ccp.org chat for connecticut
1-800 bets off for iowa 1-877-770
stop
7867 la louisiana 877
h open
why text hope new york uh new york visit
uh opgr.org call slash text tennessee
redline
1-800-889-9789 or 1-888-532-3 500 va 21
plus 18 plus new hampshire
stick with us physically present in
arizona colorado connecticut illinois
indiana iowa louisiana michigan new
hampshire new jersey new york oregon
pennsylvania tennessee virginia west
virginia wyoming where's gary goldman
when you need him i know a minimum 5
deposit required eligibility
restrictions apply c h t t
p dot
slash slash draftkings.com
sportsbook for details period
well they're both kind of me right i
like them both they're both you you know
just even from this no pressure you know
we i love abbreviation yeah and all that
stuff
especially wishy
i am poppy
they're both funny or chrissy down the
middles or chrissy grave zones
i wouldn't do those i want to do those
okay so those those don't pop to me like
the other two especially where she and i
and poppy especially weshie is funny i
am they're both good i mean they're both
really good or size 36 waist well that's
what i thought you were going to end up
doing are you 36 now no that's that'd be
a lot
still 38 oh really well that's funny
that's funny still 38 ways
but the thing is does it get confused
well i mean nobody saw the one on comedy
center right still a 38 waste is
hilarious
yeah we'll see well i think we'll see in
the edit the name because the name is
important you know especially for the
thing is with youtube you deal with
algorithms you deal with it's a whole
thing you're out of 38 how old are you
37. oh if it comes out when you're 30
you can just name it 38 waste w-a-s-t-e
how about i name it 37-38 yeah i'm 37
and this 38 waist is funny w-a-s-t-e
yeah yeah
but uh yeah so i'm i'm happy about it
and then yeah and what was so the crowd
you were telling me
because you were in new york not long
ago you were at the beacon and that was
like a 3 000 seater and now this is only
a few weeks past that and you have to
sell another 800 tickets 800 tickets and
most of the people who saw me at the
beacon bought tickets to gramercy so
what was that like what was that i kind
of i'm the person that i can't not call
out the elephant in the room when i'm
performing live i just can't so i said
to them i should have done this special
at the beacon i messed up you probably
heard some of these punches before just
laugh like you never heard it before
because i need this [ __ ] to get on
youtube you know like whatever i made
that like a joke did you and you're
going to keep that in or no that was
just a little bit i guess we'll see in
the edit maybe maybe not we'll just
waste a valuable time but yeah we'll see
maybe at least for a clip yeah i mean
we'll see that's the good thing about
putting it out on youtube or having i
mean this is just even outside of comedy
just when you own something outright
then you do what you want with it so
there's literally
any idea we have
pimp and i just talk about it love it
and it happens
if somebody else owns it it's like they
have their hand in this even netflix
like oh it would only give you three
clips or this
not this this is just like whatever i'd
like to do with it right i can do with
it so you know i'm looking forward to it
and i hope that it gets you know the
views that we're hoping
it looked great it i mean it looks
really i mean i hi homeless pimps
directed and he hired his staff of guys
and it really i mean even my agent who's
a you know has
very like real high profile clients was
like this looks better than a lot of the
things i've shot
for big corporations right because
they're like it just is amazing and the
venue loved working with them it was
great that's awesome
i think honestly where are you going to
film yours where where do you want it so
i don't i don't know we're starting to
talk about that i i i think somewhere on
the road i don't know if i would do it
in new york yeah
i don't know i i mean new york this will
be speaking of the beacon may 14th
will be my first time headlining new
york here at the beacon theater uh
tickets are on sale right now but i mean
i feel like that's that's the one for me
to go back there a few months after or
the same year or back in new york city
i'm saying i don't know if i'd want to
do that i i feel like i'm trying to go
to austin
in the last i was there in 2019 and this
year both times i've sold a ton of
tickets both time all four shows were
like the hottest crowds ever boston is
hot how about you ready for this you
know where else i think you'd be good
not a lot of people do this here do it
there london what if you did your
special in london we talked about is
that too much we talked about it i don't
know i want to make sure that everything
will translate over there of course it
would they invented english yeah
[Laughter]
yeah i mean i haven't been out there too
and they were great crowds when we were
working
there's something there's something to
be said there too i don't know but i
want to come to the uk all you uk folks
haven't been there in a long time
yeah i'm coming there i'm gonna just as
soon as i'm done with this tour i am
going to tour the uk so i hope to see
you guys but yeah i i got to figure it
out but i'm telling you i think that if
i don't
there's only a couple of places i'd want
to land depending on what their
strategies are whatever and if not i
think the move is really just the same
like put it in the hands of the fans to
be able to share it as much as they want
i have to control it as much as we want
yeah and it's not about really making
money at that point it's just about it's
just about gaining traction and gaining
views and gaining more fans my thing is
like you know i think i've said this on
this podcast i know i said on christy
chaos but you know what oprah says the
money always comes second that's what
i'm thinking about with this special
it's like some money at all i paid money
for it like i lost money but the thing
is god willing it brings me to another
place in my career that the money then
will come right it has to come right you
know that that's that's the thought yeah
and it feels you know what i feel good
about too and again this is just not
just about comedy this is
people watching at home like even if
you're not in comedy
just having ownership of it and just
doing it the way i want to do it
if it does well or doesn't do well i
know that it's all on me so it took take
so much pressure off me yeah because i'm
happy with it now the way no one else is
going to do mishandling nobody i can't
blame nobody but myself and that's a
beautiful feeling where it's like you
know other specialists like oh they made
me cut that i had to change this one
this is not that i said exactly what i
wanted to say it's like rage against the
machine says what do they say we got to
take the power back yeah it's like bane
says take the city it's yours take the
city it's yours it's yours
bane i found the cure now i've lost it
does he say that no that's uh
that's uh
sean connery oh okay r.i.p welcome to
the rock he died
sean connery had there's no way sean
connery's alive you're the man now dog
short connery's dead no he's not dead
he died just a year and a half ago on
halloween not even a year and a half ago
yeah oh i didn't know that yep wow i had
no idea
who do you think for an older woman
who's like
like who's is it shaun connery like
who's the hot old guy is it shawn connor
is it clint eastwood robert redford
maybe robert redford something like that
did you ever see that club sean connery
on barbara walters where he's like i'll
hit a woman once in a while no but let's
play it
it's kind of wild
i loved it it was like 40 years ago just
with bobby dubs would you have sex with
barbara walters when today
10 years ago
10 years ago that's a tough question i
would say no because i think she was
like 80. i know sean connery regrets
this conversation you did an interview
in which you said
not the worst thing to slap a woman now
and then as i remember you said you
don't do it with a clenched fist it's
better to do it with an open hand
yeah remember that yeah yeah
i didn't love that i haven't changed my
you have it no
not at all you think it's good to slap a
woman no i don't think it's
good i don't think it's that bad i think
that it depends entirely on the
circumstances and if it merits it yeah
and what would merit it well if you have
tried everything else
and women are pretty good at this
they can't leave it alone
they don't want to have the the last
word then you give them the laugh last
word but they're not happy with the last
one they want to say it again
and
and
get into a really provocative situation
then
i think it's absolutely right
by the way sean connery has been married
to michelin for 31 years and we have not
heard a single because you have cte
because that is
wild what he just said kanye what wait
is this pete davidson reacts to kanye
west's video is that real what are you
talking about
look at that he didn't really he didn't
really react to that i just heard there
was a statement that he thought it was
funny because robert patterson the new
batman played it out loud in a bar or
something some [ __ ] it sounds like
[ __ ] i don't know it sounds like he
said he thought it was funny
oh okay and this is probably a vlogger
yeah i was about to say like there's no
way he said anything about it that's
wild if he did
no this is just simple okay that's a
[ __ ] oh god i hate people so much
um
yeah dude the sean con the thing is with
a guy like sean conner from an old
school though but like where he just i
know it's not okay but like he just
thinks like there was a you have to
understand like there's a cancel that's
that no
there wasn't exist there was a guy alive
like
in the you know probably like the
1940s or something like
my our parents were alive and there was
also a guy alive who had legally married
like a 13 year old girl yeah like jerry
lee lewis yeah that's what i'm saying
like so it's like there's just like back
in his day sean connor say it's like i
guess it was just okay to hit a woman
now it's just like you know not wife
beating is common in europe and is
endorsed by the church as the loving
husband's means of correcting his wife's
fault can't be real 14th century roman
catholic church rules of marriage
exhorted christians husbands to beat
your wives soundly not out of malice or
rage but out of concern
so in the 1300s
out of concern i love you
i'm concerned with the way you've been
acting yeah that's insanity yeah dude
um domestic abuse during the 1950s was
not considered a crime but as a family
matter and law enforcement would not get
involved i'm telling you i didn't i say
this to you the other day remember we
talked about this once on a podcast
where it's like the the the law getting
involved in family situations is like
such a new thing yeah it used to be like
the founding fathers were like no the
law is about
your family is your family you make all
the rules you're self-governing whatever
you want to do yeah look at this it's
true
family violence became an issue with the
influence of the women's liberation
movement in the 60s and 70s as the years
progressed domestic violence in american
society began to see
began to be seen as a violent criminal
act as the attitude toward family
violence began changing so did the
criminal justice system like you see how
slow everyone was to change the basic do
you think there's something we're
missing right now oh tons
what what do you think i mean the thing
that that was right in front of us is
gonna be i think that like you know um
like in the digital age like you send
like an unsolicited like sex pick or
something like that like i think that is
big i think certainly cryptocurrency
things are gonna be a huge
um
thing that's gonna all the things that
we're doing right now with
cryptocurrency or i am or whatever will
be illegal in five years you know like
you there's probably going to be some
way regulation some regulation um
i think uh
what else is there like um
you know i mean dude i mean even like
just look at the language that we have
like even even some of the jokes on
very you know family-friendly shows they
would never make today like you just
would not do it today you know it's wild
it's wild you know like like
even now i mean what about even even
like um jokers i bet you there's been
sketches that are pranks from 2011 to us
12 where like you know you had to do
something with like um you know i don't
know getting in somebody's space or
something like that yeah you would not
you could not do that now yeah probably
i guarantee you probably probably even
the clips i make for you guys in 20
years will probably be like oh yeah
it's going to be terrible you know well
i think the one of you laughing and
pointing at joy behar falling the other
day oh my god did you see her fall no
tell me it's on camera
and then and then i want to do you ever
seen shaq falling no
this morning dead on the [ __ ] floor
are you serious yeah shaq's actually
doing a voiceover for us for jokers is
he yeah are you gonna actually get to
meet him or is he gonna do it remotely
he wants he we can have him on a show if
we want but he he's gonna do a remotely
we did it look look go go back go back
go back oh watch watch
[Laughter]
falls right off the chair
ah and now go shack falling go shaquille
o'neal i mean which one you think is
better i think can we play the audio for
the shack following you really when's
the last time you fell
oh
in your driveway in my driveway
yeah this is real look watch
i think i haven't seen this actually
he's crying
no let it play yeah
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
he goes you set me up bernie ernie's
like i physically couldn't wrap that
around your shirt and the camera just
goes to his shoe
the the the nba on tnt broadcast of
shaquille o'neal ernie johnson uh kenny
smith of charles barkley is the absolute
best
sports analysis sports show
ever created i mean they talked about
gas prices yesterday for like 30 minutes
did you see that clip where they're
talking with shaq's shacks telling them
that like uh you know the way to like
you know save money on gas is fill up
your tank when you're halfway full and
then you save money and kenny's like
that makes no sense what yeah he's like
he's like and then they like just keep
talking about it and he's like
they want and like they're trying to
commentate on the game and ernie john's
like we need to speak about bass boys
ernie wait a second
can you pull up shack gas prices oh we
got flag for this pimpy probably
yeah all right yeah uh oh shaq shaq it's
a shot you put you on yeah shack gas
prices whatever clip oh oh old shack
video about gas price goes viral okay so
it was an old video i thought it was
more recent um
look
because i told them i didn't want to get
a certain vehicle because of the amount
of gas i would have to spend it cost
like 80 dollars to fill it up get up and
he said
then you said
when it gets to half then you put 20
odds you bring it back to full yeah but
if i keep i would have to stop off and
still 180. no you wouldn't no you
wouldn't why you're complaining about
zero you'll spend 80. right when it gets
to half you put 20 then when you get
back to have you put 20. but i'll keep
stopping putting 20 in it it'll be 80
the same amount of gas
i'm driving the same amount of gas the
average human stops once a week for gas
right which you you only work here twice
you would probably have to stop maybe
maybe once every two weeks
don't even try it this is all this is
borderline travel more than me this is
bordering on what's closer
there's another clip that what that
means is if yeah what that means that's
wild that he said that no but it's wild
but it keeps going on we continue to
watch it but the reason why ernie john
says west coast the moon is shaquille
o'neal goes he goes um
he goes uh they're talking about
something i don't know how it gets
continues when chad goes chuckles losing
me he was like um he was like
uh how far is the moon how long does it
take to get to the moon and then they're
like you know i don't know he goes i bet
she takes longer to get to california
and they're like
why why would you say they go well i
could see the moon i can't see
california no because we're in atlanta i
can't see california but i could go
outside right now and see the moon and
they were like shaq it did oh that's
amazing and they keep go but then that
was another thing that was like they
played i was like hilarious because
these guys are perfect because they're
never trying to be funny right they're
just talking
but this goes on for another two minutes
where they keep he keeps you want to
keep playing it
on that you're cool well you're a good
time i don't want to get played forever
i do want to watch it if i only if i
didn't let my guys get down i wouldn't
have to fill it up as much
no i'm saying you're complaining about
the eighty dollars that's what the
conversation about you you're four times
20 is 80 because i'm gonna stop four
times no you're not gonna stop four
times no you're not gonna stop four
times not in one week you're not
anyway
the west coast is closer than the moon
if you let it get to zero right monday
through friday right then you got to pay
80 to fill it back up right okay but if
you let it get you on wednesday and you
pay twenty
right but if wednesday it's going to be
40 and then on fridays will be 40 20
yeah it's gonna be 20. no
okay it's gonna be 20. about half
half of 80 is 40. but no this is what
i'm saying i i am okay so if i every day
if i didn't if i said you're going to
have to put gas in every day don't play
me right now i'm not playing though
don't bother with me right now
i'm sorry like i really want to know
because i want to get this call but no
listen you want
you're complaining about the 80 dollars
yes right so i'm confident okay so 0 is
80. no question all right at full is 80
right yes if it gets a half that would
be 40. right no question if you put 20
and then you bring it back up to three
quarters
right no if i put 20 in it'll get to one
quarter jeez yeah but it'll be three
quarters it'd be three quarters full
three quarts empty no three quarters
full but who's off first
let's
[Laughter]
they say like when they do their
production meetings or whatever like
there's like every other team there's
like there's a plan you know they have
things that they're like whatever just
give us the score
he said we can come on with them yeah uh
i i met him on that show yeah you have
to come on anytime you want like he told
me at an upfront a couple of years ago
you should i mean it's so
laugh out loud funny and then you ever
see the one with shaq get stuck in the
mate like where they say the
simulation's real where shaq's just
staring
google shack simulation uh tnt shack
simulation we we might have to cut all
this out though right i don't wanna i
don't wanna not get ad money or anything
i don't know
oh glitch in the matrix go to 114 glitch
in the matrix this is like real
like where it's a little like
there's not a joke or anything like this
this is like just happened like live
shack look so weird
what
watch
could only be the
musical stylings of victor oladipo who
is the reigning two-time
champion of the all-star weekend
uh player uh
talent show you are talented i gave you
a little credit on that a lot of credit
you're very talented i mean
it's just frozen that can't be real no
it's real that had to be that had to be
someone edited that and put it up online
no this happened like live on the air
people were like tweeting like what
happened to shaq did he have a stroke
like it was a whole thing
and then he just comes out of it i
remember seeing this yeah nobody's even
noticing
what how wild is this yeah
that looks like it's frozen no that
looks like it's frozen it'll look real
it looks like paul's television
do they show him come out of it yeah
new york
new york
well yeah
i mean look i mean one of the i i i
think from what i've
heard it was real
what yeah
see this yeah
you may have had a seizure they're
saying
um you know however not all seizures are
just you know yeah that's wild yeah wild
right
dude i want to eat a thin mint shake
yeah literally we can eat the whole
thing
i'll eat the whole thing all right the
whole
um yeah so wait i don't know where we
cut out here but uh yeah well listen
we're ready lunch we do have to eat
lunch right now we gotta eat lunch
and um
listen
sal yeah i love you i love you too do
you really though of course i love you
so much really nuts genuine of course
kind of question is that
okay rosa's going to be so mad at this
ending
it will end like taste buds i know i
still love you babe
i still
love you too i love you too that's it
that's how we on taste buds oh really
every app whoever loses whoever wins
says i still love you babe no yeah
whoever wins says i still love you but
we said i love you too that's the output
that's the out point yeah which we don't
have one here so we're just going well
this is we usually
yeah yeah so i mean we should we could
go out with like like shaq just a glitch
in the matrix yeah what do you mean like
i blinked this has been happening
don't be a fake don't be a flake don't
run away from your feelings
[Music]